there's nothing i love more than an
unpredictable ending or a juicy plot
twist
just when you think everything is going
according to plan something happens that
throws everything off course
and makes you agonize over your next
decision second guess
decisions you've made until that point
or just complicate
everything in general with that said
it's time to buckle up and ride the
roller coaster plot twists and turns
as we check out 12 of the biggest in
games before we take off be sure to like
and subscribe to our
channel lastly this is obviously going
to be
full of spoilers so this is your
official
and final warning alright let's go
albert wesker is one of the most
diabolical villains
and he started off his reign with a good
old plot twist
25 years ago in resident evil wesker
rose through the ranks and became the
captain of stars after serving in the us
military for years
so it came as a bit of a shock that
wesker was actually an umbrella spy
all along wesker made his big reveal as
a double agent to jill before releasing
tyrant to kill the remaining members of
stars
he would then go on to be a real pain in
the ass for chris redfield and friends
for quite some time
until he was thrown into a volcano and
blasted with rockets
although if there's anything we know
about wesker he does like to play the
slow game so
i wouldn't be surprised if we saw him
again one day
by the end of pokemon gold and silver
you've traveled across both the johto
and kanto regions
battled 16 gen leaders and handed out
elves to each member of the elite four
you take a final cruise through mount
silver to find that there is still
one final boss to defeat without a word
from your opponent you're thrust into
battle against this mysterious trainer
once the fight starts we find out that
it's none other than red
the original trainer from pokemon red
and blue
red had succeeded in becoming a pokemon
master
and now that he was the very best you
had to battle him and his squad of
pokemon
which included charizard blastoise and
of course
pikachu the long-awaited final fantasy
vii remake
released last year and while it may be
called a remake
it's clear that it's a whole lot more
than that while some fans
may have been expecting an exact
retelling of the original story
it turns out we could be in a different
timeline altogether
which is a bit of a plot twist there are
major differences in the story compared
to the original
so even though we may know the events of
ff7 they are not playing out as they did
before
which is definitely keeping us on our
toes for the future installments of the
remake
jealousy greed and paranoia
we didn't know it at the time but these
would be all of the ingredients for an
inevitable backstabbing at the end
of vice city tommy and lance teamed up
to take down ricardo diaz which led to
tommy saving lance's life
before they eventually succeeded in
their quest for vengeance
surely lance wouldn't betray tommy after
all that right
wrong lance was fed up with feeling
second best to tommy
and wanted more control and more power
so in the final mission of the game
lance reveals he's been plotting against
tommy and joining forces with his former
boss sunny to take him out
however this is tommy rossetti we're
talking about here
he wipes out sunny his goons and lands
to solidify his dominance over vice city
once and for all braids unique
platforming and time-bending techniques
paired with the classic tale of saving
the princess
is almost what the game is all about
it isn't until the final level that we
discover we aren't really saving the
princess
at all throughout the game we get a bit
of foreshadowing that there may be
something more sinister at play but we
only see the full picture
once we get close enough to the princess
to see that she was running from us the
entire time
we had actually been playing the whole
game in reverse
because that perspective fit the
narration of our so-called hero
we are not the hero though we are in
fact a total stalker
call of duty has had quite a few twists
in its lifetime
but nothing stings more than the
betrayal that general shepard hands you
in modern warfare 2.
after losing 30 000 of his men in the
events of modern warfare
shepard's new mission is growing an army
to take out makarov who rose to power
and became shepherd's main target and
main distraction
within this new army is task force 141
which is composed of highly skilled
soldiers such as ghost
soap and price as we're led to believe
that makarov is our only threat
we continue to carry out shepherd's
missions only to be shot in cold blood
after unknowingly delivering the last of
shepherd's incriminating evidence
directly to him the mission itself being
titled loose ends puts everything into
perspective
as shepherd was merely tying up the
loose ends of his own plot
so he could be seen as a war hero
when it comes to family many will do
everything they can to keep them
safe this is what made john marston
strike a deal with the pinkertons
who were holding his family hostage and
working with the us government
to clear out the last of the outlaws
roaming the plains
the deal wasn't an easy one either jon
had to kill his former gang members
in exchange for his family's safety
while jon does succeed he doesn't quite
get the safety he expected
not long after returning to his ranch
with his family having done the deed
u.s soldiers were at his doorstep
looking to tie up a loose end of their
own
jon sends his wife and son away while he
makes his final stand
truly saving them once and for all with
his sacrifice
star wars knights of the old republic
throws you into its universe
and tasks you with taking down the evil
sith lord dark malek who's been
rampantly destroying your fellow jedi
thanks to his training under the
all-powerful darth raven
once you're finally in the position to
get face to face with malek
you realize why you're giving him the
business you
are darth raven and have been
brainwashed by the jedi to fight for the
good side
not only are you responsible for the
sith lord that you've been trying to
stop this whole time
but you're also handed a difficult
decision to make
stop dark malek or regain your power and
fight on the dark side
once more following along with the
brainwashed theme
you already know that bioshock would
make it on this list
being hailed as one of the greatest
twists in all of gaming
would you kindly took on a life of its
own after its big reveal
after surviving a plane crash you make
your way through the crumbling failed
utopia of rapture with the help of a man
named atlas
who politely guides you through each
mission and helps you figure out what it
is that needs to be done
would you kindly is one of atlas's
favorite phrases and tends to go
unnoticed through most of the story
until you get to andrew ryan the founder
and leader of rapture
here you discover that atlas has not
only been pretending to be someone else
all along
but also kidnaps you as a child and
brainwashed you to do his bidding
he does so by triggering his mind
control on you by prefacing each task
with the famous line
would you kindly would you kindly would
you kindly get this would you kindly
find that
would you kindly find it do you kindly
head to ryan's office
this means every action you made until
this point was all a part of frank's
plan
and makes you think back to every time
you heard that insidious phrase
joker and bats have been at each other's
throats for as long as we can remember
and arkham games made their ongoing
rivalry trickier than
ever after being infected by joker with
a deadly virus batman had to find a cure
and stop joker from continuing to infect
the entire city
it seems like joker has been healed from
being infected himself
which makes batman's quest even more
difficult
however in the final scene we see that
the healthy joker we've been battling
this whole time
wasn't the real joker at all it was
actually clay
face who definitely deserves an award
for superior acting that even fooled the
world's greatest detective
we're given tiny clues to this reveal
throughout the game from harley's little
quips to detective mode showing joker
without any bones
but it still caught many players by
surprise
we traversed the galaxy as samus fought
pirates
vanquished aliens and did it all in our
stylish spacesuit
however we never got a glimpse of the
one behind the suit until we defeated
the final boss
and what do you know samus takes off the
helmet and we discover
that this kick-ass bounty hunter was a
woman the whole time
for the 80s this plot twist was not only
unexpected
but would pave the way for female
protagonists in games and solidify samus
as one of the first
and most iconic women in video game
history
[Music]
this is the most recent game on our list
so we've put it last
just in case you haven't gotten around
to playing it just yet
the last of us part 2 is full of twists
and while the death of joel is a major
one of its own
it did set the story into motion while
simultaneously ripping our hearts out
however an even bigger twist is making
you play as his killer
afterwards what we originally thought
was going to be ellie's revenge quest
turned into abby's revenge quest too as
we discovered that abby's father was the
firefly surgeon that joel killed
in part one the story begins with ellie
and abby in a clear-cut
good guy bad guy situation but once the
tables are turned you start to see that
they aren't so different after all
getting revenge no matter who or what
you have to kill to do so
seems to be the game plan in this
post-apocalyptic world that comes down
to ellie being the one
to break the cycle which is yet another
plot twist of its own
alright so which one of these plot
twists left your jaw on the floor
which ones did we miss let us know in
the comments and leave us a like and a
sub if you enjoyed the video
because we've got a whole lot more over
on our channel and new videos coming out
daily
for everything you need to know about
games thanks so much for watching and we
will see you next time
[Music]
peace
[Music]
you